Rachel's in Illinois hi Rachel how are
you I'm doing well they pallet yourself
better than I deserve what's up I just
have some questions I'm trying to get
started with my debt snowball and I have
gone through financial peace my
understanding is you start with the
lowest and you work towards your highest
debts as far as paying them off to get
some momentum correct but I have some
interests I have some interest rates and
payment plans that I'm not sure if it
kind of changes the scenario I like my
lowest loan is I have $50,000 a student
that my lowest alone is about $1,900
it's at an interest rate of only three
point eight six percent and I'm actually
on a payment plan that's 20 years and
contingent on my income so I only pay
about $130 a month on that alright my
federal loan whatnot McCallum on my
private loans it has a five point nine
five percent interest rate and I'm
paying four hundred and sixty dollars a
month on my federal loans all right
private loans private loans is the
buying so what's the balance on that you
said my total balance on that pile on
the private that you're paying for 60
young hold mounds with about forty
thousand across five separate long that
one want to see for 60s across five
correct okay so that's not we're not
going into individual loans or what we
list regardless I can't restrain you
have one that's nine hundred what's your
next smallest one my next smallest one
is two thousand one hundred eighty
dollars so part of that federal payment
that I make of 130 a month 130 a month
okay not the 460 yeah okay what's the
next moment right the next smallest is
three thousand four hundred fifty
dollars and that is part of the 460 that
I payment so when you pay that off and
drop the 460 yes that's my understanding
again if I need a check as small as the
largest and
what's your household income my
household income between me and my
husband is about I would say 65 I bring
home about 44 mm-hmm okay and your total
student loan debt was 50 you said right
all right okay what other that's other
than student loans oh he got we have a
mortgage my husband's been married
before he owes over 28 whoa weeks over
20 in attorney fees things like that
okay so he's not he has never been in a
good financial position since the
divorce
I am the planner so I kind of helped him
fight well I don't I hope that already
not good good yeah we're working
together we have debts we have an income
we are paying things off yeah here's the
thing you're gonna knock out those first
three or four so fast that this
discussion mathematically becomes
irrelevant okay because I mean you can
be paying at a rate of almost $2,000 a
month towards your debt with what you've
described to me okay
you should be and so I mean like three
months from now most of what we just
talked about it's calling four months
from now it is you know and so you're
just going to plow on down through there
see if you make sixty five thousand a
year and you pay twenty four thousand a
year your debt free in two years not
counting the attorney's fees but I mean
that's where we're headed and and I
think you'll be able to do that so the
point is it's all gone so quickly that
the math stops being an issue the
interest rate on the math stops being an
issue or the payment rate the 460 versus
the 130 and all that stops being an
issue because it's just gone and it's
gone so fast that it mathematically you
just doesn't it doesn't affect anything
anymore the type of things you're
discussing matter if you're if you're
dragging something out ten years but
you're gonna be done so fast if you lean
into this the way we teach you to do and
you get really fired up and wired up and
knock her out
that's what I would do